it's so strange how you think your
careers gonna go somewhere and I've
always kind of wanted to do TV but it
was because of that do writing for free
at The Huffington Post was what got me a
job but here we are in the Sunday
special with Greg Gutfeld and I can't
wait to dive into an exploration of his
brand new best-selling book the Gutfeld
monologues we'll get to that in just one
second but first let's talk about your
impending death so life insurance is
very important it is also incredibly
confusing which is why four out of ten
people don't have it maybe you're one of
those people and you're too lazy you
think I'm not going to die but then you
die and your family's poor well if
anything were to happen it is important
that your loved ones are taken care of
besides life insurance rates are indeed
the lowest they have been in 20 years
the best time to buy is now the best
place to buy is policy genius.com
policy genius is the easy way to compare
life insurance online in just five
minutes you can compare quotes from the
top insurers and find the best policy
for you when you compare quotes you save
money it is that simple policy genius
has helped over 4 million people shop
for insurance they've placed over 20
billion dollars in coverage they don't
just make life insurance easy they also
compare disability insurance and renters
insurance and health insurance if you
care about it they cover it so if you've
been putting off getting life insurance
there's no reason to put it off any
longer go to policy genius.com get
quotes apply in minutes it is indeed
that easy you can do it right now while
you're sitting here and you should
because rates are their lowest in 20
years policy genius is the easy way to
compare and buy life insurance go check
it out right now I've used policy genius
myself I've explored it is easy it is
fun
well fun might be an overstatement but
it is worthwhile go check it out policy
genius com that's policy genius com let
them know that we sent you alright Greg
thanks so much for stopping by I really
appreciate it my pleasure thanks for
having me check out this book folks if
you haven't checked out this book it's
because you're stupid this book is
already nearing the top of the
bestseller list and there are times in
the Wall Street Journal the Gutfeld
monologues it has many pictures of Greg
Gutfeld yes notice it's glossy - it's a
book that is matte and gloss Wow I know
it just has all the qualities that well
you need to read a book by its cover
yes exact has all of the clothes from
The Brady Bunch
so are these actual live photos from the
set or no we recreated them because I
don't think we were allowed so I said
just find I find me sit me down make me
talk and then that's what happened
so the book is really clever for those
who have not picked it up yet well the
book is is it starts off with this this
long essay about president Trump's
election that I wanna get into with you
in just a minute here
but it also goes through a bunch of your
old monologues and it has your sort of
commentary on your old model right which
is really it's like the Talmud of Greg
Gutfeld monologue is really it's really
great that way and I think it's a useful
exercise that I think honestly most
pundits should do because going back and
looking at your old stuff in determining
what was stupid was hard it was like
because I didn't remember a lot of the
stuff that I said I'm incredibly
repetitive so if you're on TV every
single day you don't really realize how
repetitive you are that same kind of
jokes that you make and I would go
through and I go God some of these jokes
are just so hacky like every time I was
I would talk about a left-winger I would
mention like a piercing or patchouli I
just I would just drive into that that
Lane and I'm going I got it so that so I
decided in this book to call myself out
so there's like half of the book or the
monologues and the other half of just me
saying this is stupid this is wrong
whoo you got it right here a lot it was
like basically I'm heckling my own book
and uh but it's weird I when I go back
and I see what I've written there's a
2,000 of them so I had to pick up like
two hundred out of there but it was it's
it's just interesting how there's a lot
of the things kind of like foretold what
we're going through now the stuff about
Law & Order there's a chapter on Law &
Order and terror it's all about national
security and insecurity and fear in
general that I kind of noticed a trend
and I want to talk to you a lot about
the book I want to start by laying out
sort of your life story how do you get
here because a lot of people have seen
you on the five obviously and a lot of
people know you from your work in a
variety of media including obviously in
the book area but how did you how did
you get here in the first place how'd
you go from a guy who is writing comedy
to a guy who's now on Fox News every
it's really weird because I wasn't I
wasn't a comedy writer I you know I
started at the American Spectator as a
staff assist in the late 80s but I was a
fitness editor at Prevention magazine
which was the world's largest Fitness
back health magazine no longer exists I
jumped to men's health and I became the
editor of men's health I was their
creative director so I'm a magazine guy
people think that I'm like a comedian
but I don't I never done stand-up I
never called myself one because I think
that if you're a comedian has to perform
and I don't I don't stay
up in front of people so I would never
do call myself that and also I have
comedians on my show and in deference to
them and out of respect to what they do
of getting heckled and doing five sets a
night I'm not a comedian so I was a
writer and for men's health I went to
stuff magazine in America and and did
that and got fired over something and
then I could look up you can look up
that it's all the little people and then
I and then I they kicked me out and I
lived in LA for a while and became their
director of brand development for Dennis
publishing and then from there I became
editor-in-chief of Maxim UK in in London
and that was when when magazines were
dying especially men's magazines I I
hopped on that dying horse and drove it
right into the ground
and then I was kind of like not
unemployed but I got a contract to write
a book about England and I was living
there and I had been writing for this is
how I got here this is the this is the
strangest thing it has nothing to do
with anything that I've done it has to
do with pure luck Matt Lee Bosch you
know we get standard emails me and says
hey Arianna Huffington do you know her I
go yeah she's starting a blog with this
other guy Andrew Breitbart and whatever
and I they asked me to do it and I I
can't Krystal won't let me do you want
to do it now yeah yeah sure so I email
Arianna and she's you know she says oh
yeah it's this thing whatever write
whatever you want of course we don't pay
you and I'm in London I'm like eight
what is it eight hours ahead I can't
remember from California so I just start
writing stupid stuff I wrote a recipe
for lemon squares and I wrote a
lost-and-found thing for every name at
at The Huffington Post like things that
they've lost and I would just send them
and I didn't realize that they showed up
first because I was way ahead and they
got they got the most attention because
I was them I was not a liberal I wasn't
crazy I wasn't progressive and I was
making fun of them mm-hmm and that's how
I met Breitbart cuz and rube would call
me up and go Greg you can't say that you
can't say that you can't say that about
Ariana then five minutes later he'd call
me back and he goes I apologize for
saying that say whatever the hell you
want and we became fast friends and I
think he was the one who told the Fox
people in LA about me and those guys
emailed one dude in London and I met a
guy for a drink at a
bar and the next thing you know I was
flown over to New York I met John moody
I met Roger Ailes
and it it was it happened like that they
made me a contributor and then I sat
down in a meeting they flew in my wife
and I moved we got a hotel and we I sat
across from John moody with the
expectation that this whatever I was
doing which later became red I would
take a year or six months you feel it
out whatever and it just goes okay so
we're gonna start tomorrow we're just
gonna do shows all right yeah and
they're like do you have any friends
that guests and like what it does I mean
it's like I think and like they didn't
have any staff it was just me and I'm
like going to go you negotiate just call
some friends I got to get a director we
got together and I'm like I'm going this
is I'm not having a panic attack sitting
in this office and so I go like holy
crap
I called bill Schultz pill Schultz with
a features editor at stuff magazine when
I was there and he was very funny you
know he's not he's just not a TV but
like he doesn't he's not TV ready he's
more like bar ready all the time I had
grabbed him and then this other dude
Andy levy was leaving me comments on the
Huffington Post Mike Huffington Post
buck I hired that I hide so this is the
only time in history where you could get
a job from a comment like nobody liked
when you're doing comments on a blog
dude there's no hope for you except for
one time in the universe
somebody got a job and so he got a TV
gig so it was Andy bill and me and we it
was a it was a terrible show for like
three or four months and then all of a
sudden you just kept doing it then it
got better and all the sudden became
this cult favorite we were introducing
all kinds of people to the world
Breitbart was on you were on it people
like Andrew W K Amy Schumer a crowd or
you name it and it kind of took off and
then they gave me and then they gave me
a chance from the five initially on the
five I was just gonna be the fool which
was you know do a monologue at the end
of the show and and that's it and but I
kind of like said no way I'm gonna talk
about everything and till five just took
off and that was amazing and then I got
the other show on Saturdays it's pretty
amazing story and I should
that I actually followed from a fire
what was going on with you because I was
working with Andrew at the time a little
bit and it was like yeah there's this
guy Gutfeld you definitely do read all
his stuff it's amazing and I just
recommended him for this job it's cool
it's cool hearing the first person story
I always heard the third person yeah
yeah it was nuts and that means the
stuff we would him and I would go back
and forth writing the most outlandish
stuff and it was like it was weird it
was like it's so strange how you think
your careers gonna go somewhere and I've
always kind of wanted to do TV but it
was because of that do writing for free
at The Huffington Post was what got my
job who got me a job and MATLAB ash
reading a blog called the black table
which was a Jada Larry oh and will leach
if you were on earth remember those
names they were ended up at Gawker but
that was an interview they did with me
that Lai Bosch saw and it was it's just
I guess what's weird is that none of my
prior work experience man it was just
writing for free was what did it so what
shaped your politics because obviously
people think of you as like the funny
guy first you have a pretty strong
political point of view so how did you
get where you are political I was in
high school I was naturally a liberal I
was I went to Sarah High School in San
Mateo all-boys school and you could get
extra credit for doing certain things in
certain classes and one of them was
campaigning for the nuclear freeze so I
was in the I I did that you get
signatures for that and I don't know if
anybody remembers that it was I think
was Alan Cranston was behind it but it
was to ban like the delivery banned
nuked any kind of nuclear arms from
California that's what a typical
California thing you can't transport him
so I would get stand in front of you
know church and get signatures so I was
a liberal and then I got to Berkeley and
I got I was around real real liberals
but more important and I know that you
understand this because you and I have
talked about this it's not a bad idea
gee so much as it is about the mob and
so with at Berkeley I saw the mob I saw
I was I didn't see one liberal I said I
saw a thousand and it's scary when you
see a mob in and then I often said that
the mob exists elsewhere too like you I
think you we've noticed it in this 2016
election when you felt like there was
this overpowering you know Trump issed
thing and that kind of made me like a
whoa like if you say something on the
internet you get this swarm and I
realized maybe it was for people
that's what I was me and Dana was
talking about saying it really was bots
and for people that's what it was but
it's amazing but so I'm always I think
my politics are shaped by the mob if I
sense that there's this weird imitation
behavior going on it kind of freaks me
out a little bit I mean I think it
freaks out most people but it just drove
me out of the left and it kind of drove
me out of the right into more of a
libertarian phase but you even have a
little bit of that in libertarianism
anywhere any place that there's a bunch
of people who want you to believe in
something but I think I'm more like a
reason magazine type political person I
think that you know what you say about
most people thinking individually I wish
that were true I'm gonna fight you on
that I think that it's actually what I
found more in and this has been the
great disappointment to me of my life
over the past five six years is the
extent to which people will follow an
institution so long as they think the
institution is important that's true
whether you're talking about Penn State
football or whether you're talking about
a political party people just feel the
necessity to defend any institution
especially they feel the institution is
threatened from the outside yeah another
institution and that's what I think is
scary about politics right now yeah
politics is team sport it really is and
you know you wear that now you wear the
colors and and and if somebody
it's weird I think you've learned I
think the left started this I'm gonna
say yeah I know it's petty but I think
they started it with the old Krauthammer
observation who said that you know when
you're right you think they're wrong but
the left think you're evil no question
so that's how the Raiders look at the
49ers and the Mets look at the Yankees
you're evil you're not just wrong you
are evil and I'll kick your ass you
outside of the game and that's happened
you know people get massive fights over
grown men millionaires who don't even
know you exist and that in a way that's
a lot like politics you know these are
grown men millionaires who don't know to
know you exist but I guess I lost my
train of thought here where was I going
to say about the tribalism in other
tribal show the tribalism is something
that it it's it's making it so that
people can't be friends with each other
and I think that began with the left
because it became personal like politics
is personal
among the left but for conservatives you
have other things going on right you go
if you're religious you have that and
that's actually a larger part of
your life family and liberals have
families but it always is if you're an
activist the personal is political and
so they turn that on you are evil but it
seems to me that you have to build a
sense of community around something and
if a religious person like if you ask me
what's my community yeah my commute
probably the Orthodox Jewish community
in which I live right because if God
forbid I lost all my money tomorrow yeah
the people who I'd be going to for
charity are those folks but if you're on
the Left where's the sense of community
coming from except from this shared
sense of politics yeah yeah yeah my
community is the unicorn community
that's like I've noticed that people
into unicorns are like they cut across
all like I can have leftists who can't
Sammy but they dig that he's the unicorn
guy so it's like just a very strange
thing with that but it is true people
want communities that the issue is
though like you got it like people are
too close to the fire yeah whether
you're anted like the never Trumper and
the always Trumper are can be
interchangeable because they're just too
close to the fire the only thing we were
talking about Andrew Breitbart the only
way out of that is humor is like we
talked about you and I talked about this
a while ago my podcast said like no
matter what how Breitbart would feel
about Trump he would find it hilarious
no question I'd feel that way about my
mother - my mom probably would have
started off with the debates and she
would go out she'd probably call me up
cuz she died five years ago four years
she'd be like oh I can't believe what
this guy is saying did you and then
everyday would become did you hear what
he said and she'd be chuckling and
that's how I think he worked on a lot of
people was like it was just entertaining
and it was funny if he take it seriously
and I think that's the key people are
taking this too seriously
and when you talked about your community
that prevents you from taking it too
seriously
because you have a community that offers
you more and I mean it's been all so I
see this you know III have to check
myself you know I'm married I don't have
kids I can easily just get full bore and
think about this crap all the time I
could think about it I could get it I
could lie awake it in the middle of the
night and think about what am I gonna
say and I realize it's really important
to be like my wife is not political and
she'll just say stop it it's not that
it's nothing it's stupid she just
folks a hole in it and then I'm gonna
write your right and go out hang out
with people go like I love music I do
that stuff but I think the distance from
this is really really important and
that's what my neck after I'm already
think about my next book ain't gonna be
about politics I don't know what might
be about the Brady Bunch
that'd be fine already okay before we go
any further I first have to talk about
your online security so with all the
recent news about online security
breaches it's pretty hard not to worry
about where your data is going where my
data is going making an online purchase
simply accessing your email it could put
your private information at risk you are
being tracked online by social media
sites sorry to tell you about this
marketing companies your mobile or your
internet provider not only can they
record your browsing history they're
often selling it to other corporations
who want to profit from your information
which is why everything's free online
that's why I decided to take back my
privacy by using expressvpn expressvpn
has easy to use apps they were unseemly
in the background of your computer phone
and tablet turn you on expressvpn
protection it only takes one click and
then expressvpn secures and anonymizes
your internet browsing by encrypting
your data hiding your public IP address
protecting yourself with expressvpn it
cost less than a seven bucks a month
expressvpn is indeed rated the number
one VPN service by TechRadar it comes
with a 30-day money-back guarantee so if
you ever use public Wi-Fi you want to
keep hackers and spies from seeing your
data expressvpn is for you if you don't
want to hand over your online history to
internet providers or data resellers
expressvpn is the answer protect that
online activity today find out how you
can get three months for free and
expressvpn comm slash pen that's expr
ESS VPN comm slash pen for three months
free with a one-year package visit
expressvpn comm slash pen to learn more
okay so I promised before we sat down
that we were gonna talk a lot about your
book so now I want to talk a lot about
your books over the the opening of this
book is about a thirty five page essay
on what happened to you during the 2016
election and i read it and i found
myself nodding along because i think you
and i had very similar experiences i
don't think either one of us actually
voted for president i don't know if you
voted for a third party or something i i
was had an absence eval palette and i
wrote in I wrote Hillary and I sealed it
and then I walked by one of my friends
Joni who's one of my producers but she
owned a bar in New York and I trust her
implicitly and she just looked at me she
just gave me a stare and I walked to the
mailbox and I took it back and I opened
up the thing
and I crossed out I was like but I
couldn't write Trump's name either I
just couldn't and I can't remember what
I did I think I might have put in crowd
hammer's name but I don't think I just
letting that I just went down Republican
the whole way because I New York it
doesn't matter anyway but uh yeah I was
um net but what happened to me is that
okay all you could go by with Trump are
his during the campaign were words
because that's all you got
and so it's like I'm going by his words
and I and I miscalculated I think I was
a hypocrite but I'm going by his words
and I'm going okay this guy's dangerous
I'm tired of defending him and I'm not
gonna defend him and I used the phrase
that he's like a six hour drive to a
half an hour at the beach it's like you
got to go a long way and then I'll send
you get there and he's just like he he
screws up and he says he says it crudely
or whatever and so but once he became
president then you talked then you could
focus you don't have to focus on the
words anymore you can focus on the deeds
and it's like and so when I already know
who he is he won you already know that
he can be in a hole or say all the stuff
and I just get used to it and that made
it it it cleared my mind and I could see
what he was doing and I go okay that's
pretty good
like the climate change thing was
amazing to me I've been taught the gate
pulling out of that Accord was like okay
if that's the only thing he ever did I'm
alright with it cuz it that whole thing
pisses me off I thought it was I thought
it was a hundred trillion dollars who
are never gonna see again and and then
you said you saw other things some
deregulation there's a lot the North
Korea stuff I find really really
powerful even though we don't know
what's going on I still thought it was
audacious truth like Obama always used
the phrase audacious that was audacious
you know not sneaking the Iran deal this
was audacious but anyway so that was a
that was how I shifted and the other
thing is I talked about me being a
hypocrite was that I was going after him
for doing what I do on the five and I
think he watched a lot of Fox News and
he doesn't and he doesn't give a single
F and he gets up there and he says what
he wants and I'm going like you know
what if I ran for president would I
change or would I be me and he was just
being himself and he
cracking jokes and he's his transformed
the context from a campaign event or a
debate to a roast and that's when I when
I saw that that was like a minor
epiphany for me that I go okay he's
she's working the rules in the
environment so like I was give him a
total crap for the John McCain line and
and that I realized that it was a joke
and that it was a joke in its own
horrible absurdity yeah you know heroes
don't get caught you know it's like
that's it's so horrible that it's
obviously not true and that it was a
Chris Rock joke from I don't know how
long ago and even I think trumpet said
it after Chris Rock years ago yeah yeah
so something or something around there
and so that was like going okay now that
I had to recalibrate how I look at these
things it became much easier for me but
I wasn't gonna explain them I didn't
when the phrase Trump's planing during
the campaign because I'm going like I
have other options I don't need to
explain this guy I like Rubio and I like
this guy or whatever and then but once
he became president I had to start
explaining him because he was my
president two things happen one or two
revelations one I was talking to Rick
Grinnell but he was it was before the
show and I just said I just I said the
same thing I said to you I go I don't
want a leader that I have to keep
explaining and he goes well then why did
you run Greg and I go that's it he goes
no I'm serious he goes you're gonna have
to explain everybody everybody requires
explanation included so so that's the
that's the price you pay for somebody
who's gonna win and I said what well I
would probably do less explaining with
like a Marco Rubio and then I thought no
that's not true because he's really
pro-life that feminists would have eaten
him alive like if he would have been as
evil as anything he wouldn't have said
the crazy things but he would have been
eaten alive and the way they treated MIT
over cutting somebody's hair when he was
in grade school the dog on the roof
everybody would be evil so you win and
you you'd end up having to explain
everybody well this is how the left
successfully pushed the right into Trump
is because basically they decided to
make MIT Romney the worst guy in the
world oh we looked at MIT Romney went
wait what yeah as I fine will actually
run the worst guy in the world and see
what you do it that's that's it's a
member you
saying that it's like it's like okay
let's do it yeah it's like it's like
this guy is going to you know he's going
to be I calm the orange meteor cuz he
just flies in and just destroys
everything and then I look back and I go
like oh my god there's so many thiss
moment it out this gets into what
happened to me at work as well which is
that that that question megyn kelly
asked him when she said you know you are
you've been sexy if said these sexist
things you've called women pigs and all
this stuff and I was I was sitting with
my buddy was a police officer a guy who
owns a restaurant and West Side
Steakhouse and but the wife who's also
my producer we're all sitting there and
he goes and they say and Meghan asked
that question and he goes to be fair it
was only Rosie O'Donnell everybody in
the room laughing right everybody
laughed and I still don't go ahead
that's that's a first
I've never seen that I've never seen it
and then the next day however I changed
and I changed because I was around
people I really really like and respect
who couldn't stand Trump and I could see
their point of view and there were
people that were like but Bible Trump
purse that's a good word Bible Trump
errs and but I didn't care for them and
there was there was a certain mass of
that group where everything he did was
incredible genius incredible genius and
they were being dishonest and it was
just like they were ruining Trump as a
candidate by being disciples and Andy
but then I but the people that I really
liked were you know this guy he's he's
he's going to destroy the party all this
other stuff we don't know what he
believes and all this other stuff
there's nationalism and and that's I
think I was in I was caught in this
world and then it got easier when he won
it was like now yep I can but at that
night I said the first essay in there is
about the night that he won which was a
made it was like an earthquake
watching people wandering around in a
daze the people there were people that
were telling me he didn't have a chance
that he would the election would be
called by 9 o'clock it would be over and
then watch I had this New York Times
ticker you know that round thing so it
had it I was at a bar because I was we
were doing two fives so between 6 and I
think midnight so I went to a bar to
have something to eat and
ticker had her at $199 at whose
pro-trump that yeah and he almost
started crying and then I'm watching and
it keeps moving down and but it's like
fifty percent and that it's forty
percent against Hillary and then it
becomes like seventy percent for Trump
it was it's a movie they would you were
like watching I don't know what movie
it's a movie where the whole world turns
upside down and you're watching it
before your eyes and people are like in
a daze and then she doesn't even show up
she doesn't even show up and who gets up
on that who got up on the stage esta but
that's dead and it was like that's the
movie that should be made is that that
in Kollywood had any fairness that movie
is like it make great comedy I mean the
whole thing was so just untold and you
know that I mean okay there were people
that really did believe Trump was gonna
win Trump wasn't one of them I don't
know I don't think so I know nobody who
looked at data thought Trump was guy
said I lost ten thousand dollars on that
election betting people specifically
because I was looking at the day and I
was figuring all this data can't be
wrong yeah but then it can be wrong you
know that's to be the most in your in
our lifetime
the most phenomenal phenomenal political
event in America like an audience I
think it's the most phenomenal political
shock in American history yeah just the
disparity between the popular vote and
and the and the electoral college alone
is the greatest disparity and then the
forecast like the the truth is we talked
about Trump and Trump is the center of
the political universe the truth is that
Hillary that was a referendum on Hillary
yeah everybody basically did the same
thing that you did yeah in the election
in Ohio and Wisconsin which is they just
said you know what I'm not going like
she's gonna win anyway I'm not gonna do
it yank sign today's it was the brexit
it was like if they did brexit again all
the people that didn't vote was like we
vote that's why I think and I talked
about this on the shows that if Hillary
they would never give it to her because
they hate her so much the Dems but if
she's if she got the nomination
everybody would vote yeah that didn't
vote because they'd wanted Dave and also
the rematch would be insane it would
this would be the greatest political
story to have a rematch between the two
would be a would be I mean I don't know
why they haven't somebody must be
thinking about that has they figured
that she's what now yeah twice loser and
generally they're figuring they got to
go intersectional to they're going to
try
pick somebody more intersectional than
you worry was or maybe Michael avenatti
who knows it could be any man that would
be amazing
I still think Kamala I would I hear her
talk she's forceful I also think you
know I talked about this the contrast
theory that that because there are 17
people that were similar and Trump stood
out yeah I've got the plurality in fact
that could happen with the dams there's
gonna be 17 people and it could be like
a Mark Ruffalo you okay let me take me
out of the box
out of the box could be you know you
know who's like Trump Rosie O'Donnell
Rosie O'Donnell is like Trump um reality
TV talk show host outspoken and you can
say she's crazy but conspiratorial I
mean it's almost man would that be an
open your mouth just started we get we
cannot survive this this is you just
open your mouth to this and it's going
to be a reality there we go exact in
this tape is gonna be like it could
happen
listen I think it when people joke about
avenatti I'm not sure it's such a joke
no because he's considered like the most
anti Trump person in the world
yeah and he's got this whole I'm a
pugnacious fight religion you going and
so avenatti Daniels on the other side I
mean it's just it's it's all madness I
do want to ask you though I'm you know
in that essay when you talk specifically
about you know your perception from
change but you said if I were running
what would it look like
yeah do you think it but you wouldn't
think you should run I mean that sort of
that's you have the issue and and so
when I was reading it I was thinking
that's true if you consider him in the
comedic context then none of this is
like some of its super Emily offensive
you know grabbing women by the genitals
not great but you know and even the John
McCain in comment is not great but yeah
but it's but put in the presidential
context I think this is where the left
has truly lost their mind and where a
lot of us in the election cycle are
going this is not appropriate because
the president should be something
different from a stand-up comedian or
mination maybe you think that this is
like the new reality and just embrace it
I I don't know like I was at a point
where I don't know it has he redefined
it has he changed it so that we like you
could wish that you wanted a jab but it
that wishes are coming true anymore
in fact I said in fact I don't know if
there is any going back like if he's
gonna if he's gonna run for re-election
in 2020 and he's up against the Liz
Warren and he
going to he's gonna drag her down in the
mud yeah and he's gonna run circles
around her he's gonna have the 20 was it
23 me is that what it's called yeah he's
gonna have that it's gonna shake that
around because like he went he pretty
much man he manhandled some pretty smart
people Rand Paul I mean just like I mean
it was just like simple throwaway lines
there you gotta follow up the day's if
you get any further to the end these
were like very classic lines that's
where I think it's got to be somebody
who is funny yeah that's what remember
when Marco tried to be Trump well yes
and that Marco can only be Marco yeah
and that was the big problem you know I
was I was very pro Cruz obviously during
the primaries yeah he's my boy yeah and
yeah I was telling Cruz's people like
halfway through the election cycle you
got to stop punching Ruby on Rubio's got
to stop punching you yeah you guys are
gonna punch each other out and she's
gonna run right up the middle but none
of them ever ever had the capacity to
out man Trump and that's really what I
think was people say oh maybe was his
policy you see people trying to
intellectualize Trump well maybe it's
that he likes tariffs or maybe it's that
he likes big spending it's like no no no
what people like about Trump is that he
hits people
yes that's what people like they like
watching him hit things it was great it
was great TV and it was it was just like
it was a roast I think that's where he
picked us all up when he did the to what
he did the rich he did a Comedy Central
Roast where he was I think that's where
he got it and I think when they did the
White House Correspondents Dinner and
they roasted him he was like you know
what screw these people I'm gonna do
this right back to it I want to talk to
you a little bit more about possible
20/20 entrance and some more about your
book yeah that felt monologues but first
let's talk about your sleep quality
there is nobody on the planet like you
so why would you buy a generic mattress
built for everyone else helix sleep
built a sleep quiz it takes two minutes
to complete they use the answers to
match your body type and sleep
preferences to the perfect mattress
whether you're a side sleeper or a hot
sleeper you're like a plush or four bed
with helix there is no more guessing no
more confusion just go to helix sleep
calm slash bed and guests because I have
a guest take their two minutes sleep
quiz they will match you to a mattress
that will give you the best sleep of
your life for couples helix can even
split that mattress down the middle and
they can provide individual support
needs and feels preferences for each
side they have a 10 year warranty you
get to try it out for a hundred nights
risk race you really have nothing to
lose
go check it out right now helix is
offering up to 125 bucks off all
mattress orders that's 125 bucks off at
helix sleep calm slash been guests again
because I have a guest that's helix
sleep calm
slash been guest for 125 bucks off your
mattress
I have one of these mattresses in my
house it comes in the mail you and wrap
it and inflates right in front of you
pop it on the bed frame you're good to
go I got one for my sister for her
wedding it's what she actually requested
because she had heard me talk about it
it is that good go check it out right
now it's helix sleep comm slash been
guests again use that promo code been
guests to let them know that we sent you
that is B and G you est helix leaps comm
slash been guest okay so with all that
said about election 2020 I'm in full
agreement with you that that it needs to
be somebody aggressive from the other
side it also to me needs to be somebody
who's been through the mill a couple of
times because what Trump is particularly
good at is taking people and just
ripping them down yes see if they have
any place to go that is below where they
were he will take them all the way he
drags them down to hell right there
circles now see it's not yet discovered
that he's dragged Hillary down to and
that means that my problem for you know
if you're Democrat you're looking Kamala
Harris anything okay well she's the
thing right but she's got the squeaky
clean image how long is that gonna last
by the time that yeah he really goes
after which is why I still think that
their best option is probably somebody
like Joe Biden he's just cuz Biden's
been through the ringer but I think so
too i I never would have thought of that
until recently cuz I think of the age
that he might get be up there but maybe
he's not how old is he's gonna be 78
yeah I don't will be 74 they'll hit each
other with their walkers yeah they'll
combine aged 3,000 yeah the baby boomers
will never leave us alone
yeah ever the commercials will be great
you'll get a lot of catheter ads what's
the other one you get a lot of waiting
too many hours to walk in chat the Acorn
chairlift they can spot to the debates I
should be making fun of that because
they're right they're very good
advertisers I mean by the way I want an
acorn chairlift so I'm hoping that that
sponsor me one day I don't you know it
I'm a little worried about the we talk
we also we're talking about this before
about the pendulum is this it it could
go to waste if the economy is great then
everything's gonna be great but the
economy isn't great you're gonna get
this pendulum switch its swing from
Trump to something so opposite and so
frightening ly progressive that you know
III don't even know who that could be
yeah I don't even know if we know that
person yeah it could be Bernie Randy why
not yeah why not Bernie we could have a
social we could have a socialist
president and you could have a in could
have Democrat Congress with a socialist
president
this is this is why I wouldn't you know
when people say aren't you glad have
2016 when I'm like yeah of course I'm
glad have 2016 went but I'm not gonna be
able to write the rest of that story
until I find out what happens over the
next four years
because yeah a lot can change between
now and then and this is where I wonder
whether you know president Trump we've
all gotten used to I mean the fact is I
laugh at stuff from him you're right now
that he's the president there's the
stuff his administration does which for
the most part I really like and then
there's the stuff he says which to me is
like as crappy as it ever was for the
main part and then so when I look at
that I'm like okay I can deal with that
yes I can deal with it yeah but if he
toxify the brand to the point that
Republicans lose this Cup coming
congressional election they lose the
house and maybe lose the Senate where
they lose that in 2020 and suddenly
you're looking at a unified Democratic
Congress right and a Democrat president
and what Republicans got out of that was
a tax cut and a couple of Supreme Court
justices you know then we're gonna have
to look back and say okay was this yeah
was it worth it worth it and maybe the
answer is still yes but I think that
it's a lot more of a divided like right
now it's of course worth it because we
haven't seen the downside yeah yeah yeah
yeah one one big thing could change the
whole like anything in the economy and
in it could be a big trouble but I don't
know man it seems like everything seems
to be going okay going okay the economy
seems like it's stable yeah it's it
doesn't feel like there's it's fake if
that feels kind of real and that it's
moving and I disagree with tariffs yeah
is the interesting thing is right but
here but I end up learning more about
this stuff because a he's you know
talking about and I go well maybe these
these are negotiating tactics that I'm
not aware of all of a sudden he gets the
the which i'ma call it back on track
they're gonna pay this or gonna do that
and it's like maybe he's right it's like
it's all about it's all the art of the
deal right oh and whether they're back
filling it or not maybe it's just him
saying stuff in the administration
backfills or whatever it is he still
gets credit for the stuff that happens
at the top it also means that he gets
the blame when amorosa is hired yeah
he's got to take responsibility for that
and I did there's you know he talks
about he only hires the best people that
was everybody knew that was a problem
everybody he hired Mike Flynn Steve
Bannon Rex Tillerson and Omarosa yeah I
think it's fair to say he does not
initially hired the best boy do I like
Tillerson though right it was you
remember
it was far away trim had him fired on
the toilet right away sounds great right
do you remember that like dress isn't
the deep dark truth about President
Trump is the guy actually doesn't like
firing PPI yeah I think deep down
actually he wants to be light yeah and
so he actually has to have a support and
inspire people right show you there's
that tape that came out of Kelly firing
a morose and the morose and calling up
from he's like I don't know it's good
yeah I've done that I've done that no I
do that when uh where that's kind of
like when a a guest who have a show that
I don't think the guest will work that
week you need and for reasons that that
may be I don't think that the epics will
look gel and I went and then the the
guest will call me and I go they did
what wait you got bumped for my show
well let me see about that but it was me
I bring Cisco I don't want to get it I
just don't want to deal with that your
Liana fired in the elevator yeah yeah
yeah yeah I just like it's like some
people don't want to know that it's like
dude you I need somebody like who who
has some kind of background on this or
it doesn't work with this other guest
you're too similar but I can't lie I'm
not gonna sit there talk because it
hurts our feelings yeah so exercise just
go I don't want to do it I just go so I
go you know what I can't believe they
did that
let me let me see it what we can do and
then I then I run away and hide so
here's a question for you you know what
should we take seriously watch what
shouldn't wait because you say that you
sort of recast President Trump and you
recast politics through this lens of
maybe I just shouldn't take it all that
much yeah that's seriously and it when
you take it as comedy it's freaking
amazing it is so good and this is why
the left can't handle Trump because
they're taking everything so seriously
and then if you're on the right it's so
funny and the fact that they're taking
it so seriously basically turns them
into the schoolmarm yeah this hysterical
comedy is going on right in front of ya
when should we take it seriously when
should we not take it's a really good
question because
you know I'm thinking about the okay
like the like the tweeting it did tweet
he doesn't bother me that doesn't bother
me I'm trying to think if there's
anything that I'm worth that I'm truly
worried about he's a pacifist don't you
think that let it he just wants to avoid
war at all yes yeah yeah I I did so it's
like I don't think he's gonna put us I
don't think he's gonna pull like a
Clinton and go like I gotta distract you
with a war no I think he's a pacifist
punctuated by points of rage yeah that's
like he doesn't want to get into a
conflict but if you prick his pride I
know but it's like I will fire a missile
into Syria and yeah
that's what I'm worried about with with
certain things yeah I mean the race
issue for it yeah yeah people are taking
that very seriously I'm left out of
these rallies the rallies okay you know
what
I have rally fatigue because now he's
the he's that band that does the
greatest hits wherever they go and you
see him at the fairgrounds you know
America with a band like that goes up
they do they have like the horse with no
name or whatever the song is and and so
he does these he doesn't intrude on
introducing anything really new into
these things and I think sometimes I go
like you know ago I think that this that
I'm getting tired of that and I do think
that he doesn't have to keep pricking
some of these things like the NFL Neela
yeah it's like it's like you know I say
this from the five because I think I
said he can meet with kim jeong-hoon
he can meet with Putin make it a
standing invitation to be I I mean I
would never said this before about BLM
but I would have you could find like the
the hawk Newsome's and then and then the
players and have a meeting and if they
say no maybe one will say yes right say
I have a standing offer I want to talk
to you about this I want you to persuade
me what am I not seeing about this and
that would be interesting for him to do
I think would be a great thing he's
talking about prison reform he can talk
about this but I think they don't want
to meet with him now right you know I
mean that's what's kept him both
right-wing but it also you're right it
has kept him you know the president for
a lot of people who love him but a lot
of people who really don't like him
don't see him as the president and
generally he does have the capacity to
cross especially cuz he has very good
interpersonal I mean everything that
I've heard you know him personally a
little bit yeah I've heard
like one on one he's actually pretty
incredibly charming and I'm sure he gets
along with everybody he insults like
whether it's Pelosi or even even the
Clintons
I'm sure him and Bill laugh it up about
God knows what you know they have shared
experiences let's just leave it at that
but but I do think yeah I think that it
was Dana made this point to on the five
that if let's say you get the Santa
produced lose the house I mean that
could be good for him yeah you know they
try to impeach him yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah and up but I'll say it but
maybe he'll work with he'll work a
little bit you know with them I don't
know but I think he tried to work with I
mean he's tried to work on the
immigration thing he was giving up a lot
I thought yeah he was racing hit no they
still said no right exactly is it we
didn't want to give him the wall that's
exactly right
so I had three concerns with President
Trump before he was elected and some of
them have been alleviated so my three
concerns were policy because who the
hell knew yeah and then his policies
been pretty good as we've discussed and
then there was the problem of him
toxifying the brand yeah which though is
still I think on the table and then the
third problem was sort of the soul suck
of the Republican Party the idea that
people gonna back anything no matter
what he said or did and I think that's
been sort of half true meaning that
there's still people in the Republican
Party who look at his trade policy and
they're like that you know no but you
know look at look at kind of poles of
the there's ever seen I would say the
the kind of people just professionally
the people who are in the the sort of
political class and then the rest of the
Republican base which does I think
follow him almost lockstep on a lot of
these issues yeah you know where are you
on those particular words cuz I'm still
when when I think of like what I think
is funny and what I think is not funny
yeah you stuff I think is funny is the
stuff flirting he's just mouthing off
and it's on Twitter and he's just
mouthing off but the stuff that I worry
about is the sort of toxification of
brand or the division of Americans along
lines where they didn't have to be
divided so initially to take the NFL
example I was like he's right obviously
like don't kneel for the anthem yeah
what is this nonsense and of course he's
correct but then you watched the polls
and turns out the seventy five percent
of Americans didn't like the kneeling
yeah and then he says something and no
only sixty percent of Americans don't be
kneeling I was like he wins cuz he's
still got 60 percent but fifteen percent
just dropped in terms of kneeling it was
the like the way he does it the sons of
business that was I dude that was like
and I and I like I you know Pyrus is
Mazon my show in
with somebody I implicitly trust and
that really bucked that bugs him it's
like I said why do you have to do this
it's like you know they're there these
are guys who have legitimate feelings
and grievances and they're not sons
so that's I think that's a misstep but
this is the this is the rap this is the
rally Trump where he gets up there and
he just goes off and it's like that's
the thing that that's the thing that I
I'm getting tired of but he's is it he's
now eight he's a traveling comedian
who's fell in love with the audience I
think that's what you know MacDonald
described him he said he like he's loves
the sound it's wonderful people of
laughs and it's like so he ends up he's
a performer
he's a performing to get it he says
these things that that's kind of like
would that change that harms I guess the
brand but who knows man maybe the brand
needed a kick in the pants you know and
he or the other thing there is a brand
called winning and that's like you know
I hope that sounded like Charlie Sheen
there sorry sorry erase erase erase I
said but it's like people just like
maybe they're going like he won took
over like the Ann Coulter model right
which is like okay you want to just keep
loosing with McCain keep losing with
Mitt Romney this guy won well this is
the prophecy said the older Portia
remember the abortion line right yeah
perform abortions the White House so
long as yeah but this is I think that
this is the part about Trump
that'sthat's really fascinating and also
you wonder whether there could be
somebody who takes the benefits of Trump
but without the drawbacks me know what
Trump is really good at is he as we said
he's a great puncher he likes punching
things as I said the entire election
cycle he's a hammer in search of a nail
sometimes he gets a nail and it's really
satisfying sometimes gets a baby and
it's really unsatisfying
and it's in but could there be somebody
who actually knows had a knife fight
without all the baggage because the way
that the baggage is excused by a lot of
folks on our side is we go well you know
but he has to do that to win yeah I
wonder whether it's a package deal or
whether somebody who actually knew had a
knife fight but also wasn't all of this
right what would actually be of benefit
to the party may be that it may be too
early to ask that question we'll find
out in 2020 2024 or you know what could
happen the Democrats could win by doing
we need a break right we needed back to
normal so we're gonna just give you the
most comfortable pajamas you could
you could imagine so Biden is
comfortable pajamas and then you have a
VP that's also a comfortable sweater so
it's like Center centrist likeable and
it's like we're not kidding no you know
what yeah we're gonna have to Bates let
him beat us up but we're just gonna be
like Biden mansion or something yeah
yeah yeah yeah we're just gonna like
we're gonna just relax and get through
this because America's America is
exhausted it's like it's like Trump was
four years at the amusement park and you
dad I just want to go to a spa and he
talks I think there's some truth to that
because if you look at how people are
dealing with Trump it's basically like
everything's great like I was it I was
at a restaurant with David Mamet down in
Santa in Santa Barbara drop that in and
pick it right back up but David man but
it was my best yeah yeah great have a
great day okay yes yes yes should we
save it for another time it's a little
embarrassing for me okay so it actually
is a good story okay so well so okay
tell them a story that I mean you can't
catch me I asked him to be on my show
and he's a really good man
he called me personally and he goes I'm
hi this is David Mamet and like wow this
is gonna be five years ago for red eye
and he goes I'm not gonna be on your
show I just want to let you know why and
I go okay you guys do you remember when
Andrew Breitbart and you were co-hosting
or hosting for Dennis Miller show a
couple years ago maybe he was like 2008
or and I go oh yeah yeah yeah I think
Breitbart was hosting and I was a guest
yeah and I guess you were talking about
my book the mammoth book that came up
the secret knowledge or whatever and he
was in his do you remember the comments
you made about my wife's acting and all
of a sudden I felt this rush of like
shame no one's ever done this to me
before and he goes I go
yes I do and he and I I made fun of her
acting yeah and he just said and I go no
I want to I go I want to apologize I
said I apologize unequivocally for what
I said and he goes I accept your apology
I accept your apology but I won't be
doing your show and I go I understand
completely
he said thank you I go thank you have a
great day that was it
throw that's amazing story I was having
lunch with David Mamet down in Santa
Monica I was looking around and and
everybody's it's this shishi restaurant
two hundred dollar bottles of wine and
water and the whole the whole deal and I
figured everybody in this room is
extraordinarily wealthy yeah all think
the world is ending because of the
feeling of chaos that just kind of yeah
comes off the administration in ways
Omarosa being the latest example yeah
care that Omarosa was in the
administration no it's stupid who cares
yeah like do I think that she was
actually recording national security
secrets and then she's gonna bring him
out on Good Morning America or something
no it's just it just it feels like a
constant exhaustion exhaustion I mean
I'm exhausted
yes you're exhausted like every day it's
like we measured this stuff because
we're in the news business we measure
the stuff in terms of news cycles right
I'm old enough to remember barely old
enough to remember when Obama was
president and it's only been a year and
a half yeah every every weekend Obama
land was basically like a week yeah
every minute in Trump land like we've
been doing this Times coverage in our
name we probably missed at least three
fire rates and a couple of news sites in
the time that we're taping exactly no
you know what it is I don't know if I
say it in that book or at speech I did
it's like he's removed time so
everything happens at once it's like
time is for a reason you know so you
have you can have your breakfast your
lunch and your dinner but Trump has made
it so that breakfast lunch and dinner
happens at once everything's happening
at once without time we would be all
simultaneous chaos and sometimes you'll
wake up and you'll go the lights are
that's right they'll like that Twitter
trends are not a good thing to look at
because you think the world's ending go
it'll be like Trump morose something
else Trump and it's like the world's
ending and then you find out it's all
nothing and then you turn off Twitter
and it's like that's nice
it does feel like that and I do think
the one thing that could save it could
either save or threaten the country is
the fact that both sides are repinning
pawning off each other so hard right now
yeah that it makes the left totally
crazy and this is driving them not to
nominate the comfortable pajamas right
is driving them toward the
intersectional politics in your book you
talked a lot about the identity politic
and you've been you know talking about
this for years and your monologues yeah
about the identity politics of the left
do you think that the left is in any
mood to move away from that or do you
think they're just gonna keep doubling
down I think they have no choice but to
keep mean I looked I think the right
choice is to abandon it and you see that
with like you see Bill Clinton saying
it's said as much but I don't know man
they got a lot of power they got the
loudest voices and they're that
oppressor versus oppressed ideology is a
it's a cult
it's a brainwash you can't see out of it
once you see put that filter on
everybody's an oppressor but that but
sooner or later they're gonna turn on
each other I think but I don't know how
they get out of it I would I maybe they
won't I think that it's interesting I
talked to you know some folks on the
left just as you do and I was talking to
one gal who I'm friends with Jen Koshien
over at Fox and we at Vox and we were
discussing the the the fact that she is
very ensconced in the context she's kind
of talked about the context right so
when you look at what Trump says you
have to take it for the context or when
you look at Sara's young at the New York
Times saying racist things yeah it's not
really racist cuz you have to look at
the context right and I kept saying to
her is that you know in my view yes
historical context matters of course and
yes we have to look at how groups how
group dynamics we're out of it but
that's like 15 to 20 percent of the
story in America the other so the other
85 80 percent of what you do in America
is basically you making individual
decisions right but it's a very
comfortable place to be and I think both
sides are falling into this that we we
have stopped thinking about the
individual decisions we make and now
we're looking to politics to solve all
of our problems right that's actually
creating this reactionary cycle where on
the right it's like well my town is
going away because of the the freaking
chinese and Mexican yeah and on the
other side it's well my town is being
threatened by these all right Nazi goons
who are running the police departments
yeah yeah yeah no it is now it's a it's
two camps but then but then you said
something about nice weather that's it's
an interest you can choose like you
could choose to step away and it's like
it's like it's gone I find that it's
gone I find that social media has
exasperated all this stuff or is it
exaggerated he's assassinated or an
exasperated but uh but uh if I step out
of it it's great the only thing is if it
does if you could step out of it but it
comes for you so you end up getting
you'll be you'll be doing stuff with
your kids or something but it you can't
turn that thing off when it comes after
you I think it's my next book I'm doing
something I'm writing about like how do
you solve these these ritualistic
crucifixions you know what I mean
they're that happen oh yeah it's insane
and I think that's that's the skip
that's where it keeps going like it's
not just this
their side and our side it's I'm getting
this person and I'm pulling this person
out and destroying that person that's
what it is that make people feel so
scalping and it feels yeah it feels
great and you and I I've written about
this you got to resist the mob even if
you don't like joy read like I could I
swear if we wanted to we could have
gotten her to lose it but we did give us
conservatives we just said you know what
she said these awful things but if it
was you if it was me we would have been
gone no question you know no question
she gets she get like I defended Joy
Behar when she said this stuff about
that Chris about Christians I think yep
in the view and she had apologized I
defended her I was like they won't one
of the few people because I'm like going
like you got a stop we have to be we
have to be somewhat we have to be the
leaders if we're the winners we have to
leave but I mean I do think that we have
to set up a feeling on the left that if
they continue this that there will be
consequences yeah but by the same token
it's hard to balance that with you know
let's not destroy people just because we
can and and the fact is that we now live
in this you're exactly right I mean I
remember you know it was probably three
weeks ago now or that actor/director
mark Duplass just tweet out something
nice about me and suddenly he was
deleting it and apologize it as MAOIs
worse and then James Gunn jumped in and
then he wa i destroyed half the MCU but
literally sitting here doing nothing
right I was just sitting here doing
nothing and suddenly James Gunn loses
his job and I thought to myself like if
this stuff doesn't stop ya then in like
the Internet is bleeding into real life
the social media are bleeding into
regular life I used to think and it's a
depressing thought when you spend your
life in politics and doing political
commentary trying to inform people I
used to think that the future of the
country lay in the informed 40% there
are 40 percent of the American public or
into politics and very informed and
following the news I'm starting to think
there might be the opposite that maybe
the future of the country lies in the
60% that absolutely watches nothing that
any of us do and all they do is like go
to baseball games they watch whole TV at
night and they only spend time like
doing other things I really hope that's
the case ya know it but it is this this
this new kind of like if you have it
like if you have a bad day you your life
could be over so let's let's say you get
in an argument at Walmart somebody films
that yep
you could have a like I said this a
couple weeks ago on the 5 that at my
parent if this social media was around
with my pair
my mom would have been a meme you know
she would spank me if I was acting up in
public hears that you in fact somebody
catches that you're gone everything's
pink every it's a nation of narcs we're
all catching rollin I got him I'm gonna
put that up there and it's just like I
remember there's a Paula Dean right I
mean they're like yeah she said
something racist like she's hammered in
like the 70s yeah that's okay now let's
destroy her entire business now yeah
yeah cuz of a racist thing she said in
1973 yeah and then they just disappear
like if people are there vanette she's
vanished yeah there's a few other people
too I mean that you just go where did
they go is there an island dude where
you can people and also can people come
back right you know is can louis c.k
come back I don't I think I should by
the way I think I say like I'm one of
these people I think Louie CK should
come back yeah he didn't like what he
did was bad yeah but it's not like the
guy was you know trying to portray an
image of himself like he's a priest or
something this stuff right he talked
about this stuff yeah and you know once
he's done his time and done his
repentance it seems to me that he should
be able to like he didn't rape anybody
yeah he did some really bad stuff yeah
that's not rape and I think that we also
have no gradations right even for me
saying that he did bad stuff but it's
not rape I'll get destroyed for yeah
yeah yeah all of these things are rape
everyone is equivalent to the worst even
when you ask for a spectrum people will
see that as dismissive dismiss right
it's like I just want to like because
they say no there's no there's no spec
dad is bad that is bad yeah unless it's
like a an Asian person saying bad things
about white people then of course not
bad at all and once you divide it into
this dichotomy of good versus bad as
opposed to here's a spectrum right bad
right there's like anti black racism
which has historical connotations that
are really bad and that's bad racism and
then slightly less bad racism but still
racism is asian people saying that all
white people should die like yeah it's
still pretty bad but it's not like quite
on the level than what the KKK back as
soon as you say that sort of stuff
people lose their minds yes everything
has to be equal to everything else he's
interesting I was reading a book over
the weekend about Rwanda and you know
really light reiterating yeah over the
over the summer and about the Rwandan
genocide and one of the things that
struck me is you know when you're
talking with Rwandan genocide basically
the government said your neighbors are
now your enemies go to murder your
neighbors and the the and in three
months 800,000 people are as long as yes
right and and it occurs to you like the
development of the end of
I didn't you're an individual and not
just a member of a collective body that
is designed to go hit this other
collective body yeah that's actually
relatively rare in human history and it
only exists in certain places at certain
times and it feels like we're now in
Reverse cultivation like we spent we
spent literally millennia trying to get
to the point where we thought of
ourselves as individuals with
independent thoughts and motives and who
could stand up to the mob yeah and when
I look at the world now I think that we
have this weird idea that all bad people
that then the Nazis were basically
monsters who were not actual human
beings who are just bad who did bad
they're not saying they weren't human
being suited monstrous things they were
monsters weren't human in any way right
and so when we look at that's a very
self flattering point of view like we're
all good people you never do anything
like that I don't I don't buy that at
all I think that pretty much everybody
is capable that's what it says that I
mean it's like that this is like what is
it that like and I there's a dude do you
have you've read any is it Rene Rene
Girard is that ring a big yeah that's a
name yeah the whole idea of just like
invitation so again I think social media
I've been reading that and I've been
thinking about why is it getting worse
is because social media is enabling the
repertory Pete behavior and being able
to imitate each other and that's
creating more of a mob rule like it's
disseminating these memes in this in
these feelings so we could all just join
in and swarm you know that in like if I
don't like ben shapiro i can get a
hundred thousand people or four thousand
people who feel like a hundred thousand
i think it i think that's why it feels
like it's regressive it's going back
because i think social media is making
that possible maybe it maybe it doesn't
result in anything bad like you don't
nobody gets killed it's not rwanda right
it's all social media but I noticed that
social media does destroy careers and
that's physically justine sacco right
yeah yeah yeah she got famous yeah well
she flew to South Africa before making
an AIDS joke well maybe he's an aids
joke which in which the joke was about
it like eight aids was unfortunately
affecting black people in Africa or
something yeah yeah yeah it wasn't like
an a it was she was making a political
point right liberals would have loved
anybody would you know and she got
totally by the time she landed she was
over do you think there's any hope that
there's gonna be any cross aisle
discussion you know anytime
in your future because it just looks I
mean there's some people but it's just
yes my son found out we're not Blair I
know I don't I don't know I don't know
that the only upset I could think is
that maybe we just are moving away from
politics hopefully like most of America
is yeah I don't know I mean I hope so
too and I think that you know one of the
things that you do that's so great is
that you bring a lot of culture into
into what it is that you do and that is
space where I think that so long as the
left doesn't destroy our common cultural
space - yeah I think that we can
actually have some space so where do you
what do you want to do over the next few
years I mean look what's you what's your
goal I know these are other questions I
actually like doing what I'm doing I
enjoy I enjoy writing every day that's
the thing that I like to do and I'll
probably do as long as Fox will have me
I'm I mean I I don't know many people
who are doing what I do I'm the only me
at the network I can't think of anybody
and so I like the ping you need and not
a lot of funny conservatives yeah yeah
they're coming there there's a there's a
few though that I found on my show that
I'm like really like I had a few last
week you know and I would say that
they're non liberal like Joe DeVito and
Joe Mackey and Chris freed or these are
all young guys and I you know it's funny
I don't like even labeling them because
I don't want to hurt him right I don't
even know we get we get we get no - I
know a bunch of like major Hollywood
folks who listen to the show what I
think yeah and I'll legitimately say to
them you cannot let people know that you
ever watch any of this stuff I have a
buddy who is super hip in the music
world probably one of the hippest people
who is what was more excited about the
podcast when you did with me and will be
excited about this but I'm not gonna say
his name yeah I'll tell you after but
I'm not gonna say his name because it
would just not help him at all I mean
this guy is so hip he's like if people
found out about it pitchfork would be
you know pitchfork media well yank out
oh yeah no question I mean the list of
people who have actually been to the
offices who we will not take pictures
out because we'll say to that like this
was Duplass a mistake he came in I told
him dude don't let people know that you
were here yeah did you got destroyed
right that's how bad it is but you know
I think that hopefully there will be a
rational middle that not even in terms
of political viewpoint but just a
rational middle where people can
actually have these discussions again
that will block the podcast movement is
where it's at I really do and I and I
thought we're gonna start doing some
stuff at Fox this fox nation Sox Nation
stuff yeah yeah based on it yeah I think
so
and I haven't already right so I'll
probably do another thing but it really
I think the idea of these longer forum
conversations are really really helpful
I mean it between you between you
obviously you and Rogen Robyn's grave
Reuben and discuss the Sam Harris
I love Scott Adams as periscopes in the
morning and I watch because he's because
it's like it's a wild dude is something
else but even get him on here he's easy
kick oh you yeah I'm seeing him tomorrow
where he's gonna be interviewing me in
San Francisco and yeah he's he's
definitely his own thinker no no
question well it's been really a
pleasure to have you on I really
appreciate everybody should go out right
now and buy this very book not this one
in my hand I already own it this is one
the gutfeld monologues go check it out
it really is fantastic Greg thanks so
much for saw somebody thank you so much
[Music]
the venture Pierrot shows Sunday special
is produced by Jonathan hey executive
producer Jeremy borin associate
producers Mathis Glover and Austin
Stevens edited by Alex Singaram audio is
mixed by Mike Carmina hair and makeup is
by Jess wah alvera and title graphics by
Cynthia and gula the Ben Shapiro shows
Sunday special is a daily wire for word
publishing production copyright for
publishing 2018